from her lead role on suit to carrying a
Tostitos commercial on her shoulders to
that time she flirted with Ashton
Kutcher we're talking Megan Marvel's
best scenes on spilling the royalty hi
everybody i'm lauren zima
megan Markel is about to add a major new
section to her Wikipedia page royal but
as an actress she had already wrapped up
plenty of credits like way more than we
thought we're breaking down her best
moments and this is Megan back in 2002
on the soap opera General Hospital she's
just about 21 years old here many actors
start out on soap
I have his chart right here dr. Lambert
I don't see the notation anywhere and
yeah that was definitely a start not the
most believable paper shuffling we've
ever seen but hey we all learn and as an
actress Megan was a hustler taking parts
in commercials made-for-tv movies and
more really it was okay in 2005 she sat
next to none other than Ashton Kutcher
for the movie a lot like love credited
as quote hot girl time in 2006 a more
substantial speaking part on CSI New
York again she played a sexy character
this time showing serious skin and even
sporting a blonde wig I may have slept
with Grant Jordan but I didn't kill him
we believe you Megan in 2007 a different
kind of part she was her stunning self
on Deal or No Deal
Megan put her enthusiasm to the test on
the game show as a briefcase model
though guys that was actually good
practice for royal events do you know
how much clapping she has today Megan
also played pretty flirty though much
younger in 2008 for two episodes of the
high school drama d9 oh two one oh she
would have been about 27 then 2009
brought this Tostitos commercial and
this is definitely not Megan's voice as
her inner model that's more people then
I invited to the party
then back to those crime procedurals
they can really help actors rack up the
SAG after credits in 2010 she went down
south for a fiery episode of CSI Miami
this time for her part megan
dramatically makes her way through
falling debris
she dramatically cops she even
dramatically saves somebody all before
needing to be dramatically saved herself
and what's really captivating to me here
is that we see Megan wearing the sleek
low bun but as we all know she now goes
for a Messier bun look also I have a lot
of questions about those flames
Megan's acting deserves better than
these flames and remember remember me
the 2010 movie starred Robert Pattinson
and Megan played a bartender named in
2011 another feature film role in a
scene for Horrible Bosses Megan was far
from horrible you're way too cute to be
just a FedEx girl you've got to be like
a model or actress or something right
she is Jason Sudeikis and she's a future
princess Plus this is kind of crazy in a
2010 episode of the show castle megan
played a crime victim who was dressed as
a princess okay it was weird and it was
creepy but that is not Megan's fault you
can't prove that I killed a mere
Christina right around the time of that
unsettling plotline was the part that
changed everything for our little Megan
Markel after about a decade in the
business she got her breakout moment
when she was cast as Rachel Zane on the
show suits in 2011 I'm Rachel Zane I'll
be keeping your orientation Megan is
leaving the show to marry Harry and
she'll wrap up the role with wait for it
a wedding for her character ahead of her
actual real-life wedding
my dress so what do you guys think of
all of Megan's on-screen accolades do
you like her TV parts did you watch
suits even did you know that she was in
all these movies let me know what your
favorite role of Megan was talk to you
guys soon
[Music]